the opening scene features a man named
Miles Elliott who works as a copywriter
at pool branding firm he is struggling
to focus on his work which becomes
evident when he requests more time to
complete his project displeased his boss
turns to another coworker named Dan who
takes control of the situation and piles
more misery on miles after work the two
friends meet at a pub where Miles
wonders how Dan made such an improvement
in life in response the latter discloses
a secret he went to a spa called called
top happy that changed his entire life
since then he is much happier and feels
more energetic tell me you discovered a
rubbin tug without telling me you
discovered a rubbin tug miles says he
also hands him the spa card suggesting
that he visit the place himself back at
home miles's wife Kate as usual nags him
to have a baby and start a family
however his overworked brain prevents
from getting out of his stale and
monotonous life as he retires for bed he
looks at the spa card and contemplates
following his colleague's advice the
next morning miles contacts the spa to
get an appointment but to his shock he
learns that the charge is a whopping
$50,000 must be one hell of a tug he
thinks desperate to get rid of the
current lifestyle miles decides to risk
all of his savings and drives towards
the spa once there he is greeted by two
Korean gentlemen who brief him about the
process of modifying his DNA to create a
newer version of himself with Miles as
agreement the two men take him to an
operating room and put him under
anesthetic in the next scene miles
regains Consciousness and finds himself
in a grave covered by a plastic sheet he
frantically tears up the plastic and
frees himself but now he is in the
middle of the forest dressed only in an
adult diaper despite being in a confused
State he Ventures through the woods for
miles in a desperate attempt to make his
way home after 6 hours of walking he
finally arrives home only to hear his
wife speaking to a man upstairs
believing that it's an intruder he
quickly grabs an Axe and prepares to
attack but as he Corners him he is
shocked to learn that the man is another
version of himself when miles asks for
his identity the newer version claims
that he is a resident of this home he
also appears to know everything about
miles's life after a small scuffle the
two confused miles's drive back to the
spa which was the sight of his last
memory before the grave there they learn
that they have been cloned here it's
revealed that the two Korean experts
clone their customers and get rid of the
original one by burying them outside the
state park however their experiment is
gone wrong this time because the
original version managed to survive as a
result the experts offer them a 10% fee
refund as compensation here's five grand
enjoy a lifetime of cosmic Terror for
now the two miles have to share the same
life the scene then cuts to the
flashback depicting the perspective of
the Clone version of Miles after he woke
up in the spa he now SE seems to be
energetic and happy unlike the original
one when he gets in his car he learns
that he doesn't even need his glasses
anymore following this he runs through
the corn fields enjoying the beauty of
Nature and the sun glinting through the
stalks miles's Bliss carries over into
the office where his co-workers notice a
positive change in him he
enthusiastically presents his new
proposal which is ultimately accepted by
his boss later at home he makes dinner
for Kate and unusually shows his
affection towards her he even agrees to
start a family and Promises to visit the
hospital for a fertility test he's in
such a good mood that he's willing to
spank it into a cup following this the
timelines merge back to the present
where the original and the Clone version
confront each other and end up at the
spa after learning the whole truth
miles's clone feels overwhelmed and
dissatisfied he doesn't know why he was
created nor what his purpose in life is
in the aftermath the two of them demand
a full refund and an additional 10,000
for the trouble that they have caused
when the Koreans refuse miles threatens
to disclose their illegal cloning
practice to the FDA finally making them
agree following this the two miles is
split the cash in half and go to a
restaurant to discuss what they should
do next the original one persuades his
clone to disappear from his life
highlighting that he can travel all over
the world without any worries however
it's a poor consolation prize for a man
who feels that it's not the life that he
really wants despite being sad the Clone
version reluctantly agrees to leave
later while driving towards the airport
miles's clone receives a call from Kate
and he can barely hold back the tears
upon hearing her voice this prompts him
to change his mind and head back home
meanwhile the original miles is at work
where he realizes that his clone has
built up a career defining opportunity
his boss appears to be impressed by the
new idea and suggests that he keep
working on it however miles doesn't
understand the clone's proposal which
stresses him out unable to figure out
the solution he dials his clone for
assistance however he is taken aback
when he learns that the Clone is
actually standing outside the house the
two then head to a restaurant to discuss
the matter the original miles is forced
to seek his clones help to complete the
work project from that day onwards miles
relaxes at home while the Clone version
assumes responsibilities at the office
as the days pass by the original miles
starts drinking excessively contrasting
with the continued success of his clone
one day the Clone reminds the original
about Kate's house party with her
colleagues however miles forgets it and
ends up drinking that night as well as a
result his clone takes control of the
party and steals the show with his
hilarious stories at the end of the
evening Kate and the Clone head towards
the bedroom for some romantic time the
original one who is secretly watching
them manages to switch places at the
last minute I don't get to sleep with my
wife I do in the next scene the original
miles goes to visit his sister Maya Who
admits that she knows about his clone
she also reveals that they often spend
time together and that the Clone is much
better than the original miles wonders
why Everyone likes him despite his being
a clone to which his sister responds
that one has to make efforts to earn it
as time passes miles grows increasingly
envious of his clone and he vows to
transform himself to be more like him he
resolves to take matters into his own
hands deciding to carry on his project
work independently however it's not that
easy for him to do so during a meeting
with the company's chairman miles
fumbles a lot while delivering his pitch
however he somehow manages to impress
chairman hilston with the content after
the meeting hilston asks miles to stay
in order to talk in private he
recognizes that the work proposal is not
originally miles's but despite this he
doesn't seem to be affected instead he
gives him some words of wisdom do it
right even if you are going to cheat one
of the core tenants of sociopathic
businessmen worldwide as miles makes his
way to the celebratory dinner he notices
that his clone is already there weaving
his stories overwhelmed with jealousy
and anger miles finally decides to
reveal the secret to everyone he walks
up to the table and takes over the Clone
story as everyone watches in shock in
order to handle the situation smoothly
the Clone asserts that the other miles
is his twin brother from another city
however Kate is unable to accept this
Revelation so she storms away at home
both miles is sit on the couch one is
trying to be overly sweet while the
other is begging to be understood Kate
appears to be livid but the original
miles explains that the entire situation
was created because he was stuck in his
monotonous life he also expresses that
he needs his clone because he is better
than him and can do everything that he
can't but now that Kate is aware of the
truth they let her decide what to do
next after a bit of thinking she orders
the Clone to leave the house citing that
she can't live with two feeling bad for
him the original one makes sure that he
has a place to live and to make a fresh
start however it proves to be difficult
for the Clone to move on from Kate
because he still loves her after all he
shares the same genes and memories as
those of the original now his sole
companion is miles's sister with whom he
has a good relationship as the Clone
version confides everything to Maya she
suggests that he go out with other girls
and find true love for himself it is
probably better than looking at photos
of Kate every night heeding her advice
the Clone takes one of his co-workers
kin on a date and ends up sleeping with
her that was easy but he's Paul ruds so
yeah however he remains unsatisfied
feeling emotionally connected to Kate
the same night he sneaks into the
original miles's place and steals a
sample of Kate's hair in order to make a
clone of her he takes the sample to the
top Happy Spa but the Korean experts
refuse to work work for him fearing that
they will be arrested with this
rejection the Clone returns back to his
apartment he then decides to create a
profile for himself on a dating site but
as he enters all the required details
the only name that comes up is Kate the
scene then cuts to 5 years before the
cloning and we are shown how Kate and
Miles suffer a miscarriage in order to
put this tragedy out of their mind they
relocate to a new house in the suburbs
where they express their hopes and
dreams of living happily ever after
together over time Kate's job as a
designer starts to go well and the
couple eventually moves on in their
lives fast forwarding to 2 days before
the cloning incident Kate is seen
heading off to work by this point in
time their married life seems to have
deteriorated miles and Kate wake up to
the same alarm every morning but they
barely speak before heading to work Kate
time and again offers signals but he
ignores her completely he is clearly
unable to balance his personal and
depressed work life at one point there
relationship hits rock bottom and a
desperate Kate resorts to posting her
profile on dating sites this happens to
be the night before the cloning incident
the following morning her phone
completely blows up with messages from
prospective men on the dating sites
despite this miles does not notice as he
is also busy working on his phone the
cloning day is then shown from Kate's
perspective having a pregnancy near miss
and being fed up with mil's listlessness
she decides to put down money on
fertility treatment regardless of
whether miles is the sperm donor or not
here we learned that both Kate and Miles
attempted to withdraw the money from
their common savings account on the same
day each privately trying to improve
their lives without the other miles gets
their first and withdraws $50,000 for
the spa fee leaving Kate empty-handed
back to the present Kate looks through
her dating messages and finds her
perfect match who happens to be none
other than miles's clone she resolutely
heads out the door for a face-to-face
meeting with without telling her husband
from this day onwards she starts dating
the Clone clearly indicating her
disinterest in her real husband one day
Kate drives off to the city for a week
for her design conference 5 days later
miles receives a call from the fertility
clinic about an appointment but this
time he doesn't cancel it in a hope to
make amends in his life he finally
visits the clinic and undergoes the
fertility test in the next scene the
original miles learns that the success
of the Clones ad campaign depends on a
small town referendum intrigued about
what happens he sneaks into the meeting
only to find out that his clone hasn't
shown up yet shortly after the meeting
begins and without the Clone the
campaign takes a failing turn initially
the original miles is happy to watch his
clone's failure but he soon realizes
that his own fate is tied up in the
success of the referendum as a result he
reluctantly intervenes and persuades
some of the locals to vote in favor of
hilston the next morning the original
miles receives a call from Kalin who
asks where he has been for the last s
days here he learns that his clone
hasn't gone to work for the entire week
he then frantically tries to contact the
Clone and even leaves numerous voice
messages but receives no response as he
prepares to head out to search for the
Clone he finds a large crate right
outside his house he drags it into the
garage and opens it revealing a large
dead pig in a perplexed State he gets in
his car to head towards his clone's
apartment just then miles notices his
clone in the rear view mirror but before
he can react someone puts a black bag
over his head and abducts him the scene
then cuts to one week earlier showing
Kate going on a first lunch date with
miles's clone they enjoy each other's
company and the Clones gentlemanly
attitude has a Charming effect on her as
their conversation unfolds Kate invites
him to her design conference in the city
to which he happily agrees this explains
The clone's Disappearance from work for
an entire week the very next day the two
set off on their trip once there they
book a hotel room with a king-sized bed
where they end up getting intimate
despite the Clone being good at every
other thing he has zero experience in
the bedroom resulting in some awkward
scenes and a dissatisfied Cate in the
morning the Clone coats her with Romance
by bringing breakfast and bed and taking
her out for a jog in addition he buys
tickets for the Paris vacation which
they always dreamt of he even offers to
relocate there and start a new life
together however this proves to be too
much for Kate so she rejects his
advances somewhere deep in her heart she
regrets her actions and decides to end
everything she says that the Clone is
too great too loving and too kind which
is weird for her her real husband has
been a dick to her for so long that she
has Stockholm syndrome and she craves
more 5 days after this incident the
Clone is seen drinking at a bar there he
meets Dan who is disgruntled after
losing his job as they start conversing
miles is clone decides to reveal the
Spa's secret to him following this he
drives Dan to the woods and asks him to
dig a spot when the latter does so he is
taken back to unearth his own dead body
miles then explains everything about the
Spa's cloning practice after disclosing
that they both are the Clone versions
clone Dan is so angry at this Revelation
that he thinks of filing a case to the
authorities but clone miles manages to
calm him down he instead has a better
plan in mind desperate to live a normal
life clone miles opts to take a drastic
step abducting the original miles for
this he goes to a convenience store and
buys all the necessary abduction kits
upon preparing everything he drives
towards miles's place to execute his
plan moments before doing so he notices
a van stop in front of the house two men
get out of it and abduct miles before
driving away although it is an unusual
situation the Clone seems to be happy
about it meanwhile the original miles is
taken to the f FDA building revealing
that he has been arrested for the
illegal act of cloning due to budget
constraints miles is kept in the fda's
lactation room rather than a proper
holding facility the investigating
officers who want to get to the bottom
of this human cloning operation put him
through a lie detector test in order to
find out whether he is a clone or not
however the malfunctioning machine leads
to insufficient evidence resulting in
miles's release from custody on his way
back home he receives a call from the
Fertility clinic informing that there is
nothing wrong with him and that he is
perfectly ready to have children upon
arriving back home he notices Kate
waiting for him on the stairs she is
ready to confess her shame in cheating
on him with his clone but before she can
do so Miles stops her from talking and
instead apologizes for everything he has
done to hurt her in the past he admits
that he had forgotten to give importance
to her and only prioritized work before
she can even reply he plays their
wedding song and pulls her in close to
dance together meanwhile the Clone is
secretly watching all of this from
upstairs this prompts him to accept his
defeat so he returns back to his
apartments and contemplates shooting
himself he holds the gun to his head but
is unable to gather enough courage to
pull the trigger when the original miles
and Kate Stop Dancing she finally
reveals everything about her conference
trip including that she slept with his
clone unfortunately this leaves our guy
fuming so he grabs an Axe and storms
towards the clone's apartment upon
reaching there he grabs a gun and points
it at the Clone however he can't pull
the trigger either so he drops the
weapon and gets into a physical brawl as
they fight they turn their rage against
a table and Smash It To Pieces they also
smashed the ratings charts with this
sexiest man on Earth on sexiest man on
Earth action Breathing heavily the two
continue wrestling until the original
miles nearly Smothers the Clone to death
with a pillow at the last moment the
original snaps out of his anger and
frantically performs CPR Reviving him
back to life after this both of them lie
down on the floor and reconcile by
apologizing to each other they express
that they just want them to become a
better version of themselves just then
Kate walks in and apologizes to both
versions of Miles asserting that it's
been a monumentally confusing time for
her in a surprising turn of events she
announces that she is pregnant however
she adds that the father will never be
known because they both share the same
DNA and she has slept with both of them
despite the unconventional situation
they aren't affected by it as they are
simply Overjoyed with the fact that they
are having a baby the series ends with
the three sharing a group hug eagerly
anticipating a family together and
beginning to accept that there are
threesim in their near future subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching